je m'appelle
Dracula vous allez faire un excellent
assistant il incarne le mal nous te
protégeons 3 en la parole de la plus
respectable institution au monde
[Musique]
mes besoins sont la seule chose qui
importe la vie
maintenant la table
tout ce que je veux c'est une vie
normale
[Musique]
merci Monsieur Dieu vous bénisse ma sœur
vous êtes un héros Robert
je travaille pour Dracula le compte
Dracula
le vrai Dracula on m'appelle le maître
des ténèbres
ou encore le seigneur de la mort
tu lui amènes des gens à manger je fais
aussi d'autres trucs
nettoyage à sec c'est trop mon style
c'est d'en faire
si tu veux retrouver ta liberté faut lui
mettre la pâtée je refuse de me laisser
faire et d'être maltraité je mérite
d'être heureux tu t'expliques autrement
tu veux bien tout ce que tu mérites
cette souffrir mais les gens infernales
vont punir le monde tous ceux qui
comptent pour toi ils seront marqués
il faut se préparer et le faire avant le
coucher du soleil
[Musique]
je me suis pris
j'ai droit au bonheur
je prends ma vie
[Musique]
tu sais quand il se passe un truc de
malade et qu'on dit oh ça va aller j'ai
vu bien pire ce que je t'ai vu faire là
ça sera mon pire à moi c'est vraiment
pas ce que je préfère dans ce boulot